It’s hard to believe it’s been a full
one hundred days since I began my journey
– no, my mission – into the beating heart
of the SCP Foundation.
I, Stathis Stern, risked detection, my safety
and even my own life for this cause, and I’m
sure that makes you wonder why on Earth I’d
be foolhardy enough to put so much on the
line.
Well, my reason is the best – no, the only
– reason that matters: for the sake of art.
I decided early on that recording my findings
was essential, both for posterity and so that
the art world may know just how dedicated
I have been in my pursuit of true inspiration.
It all started over three months ago, that
was when I first managed to embed myself in
the SCP Foundation.
Naturally, I never would have jumped at the
idea of having to fraternize with the likes
of the Chaos Insurgency.
Their methods are far too brutal, their organization
seeped in violence that trivializes my own
pursuit of a deeper meaning.
But even I have to admit, the Insurgency’s
methodology can yield results.
They arranged for a convenient ‘accident’
to befall a lower-level researcher, after
they returned home from Site-19; the SCP Foundation’s
largest and most infamous facility, home to
many of their equally-infamous anomalies.
Thanks to a falsified identity and phony transfer
order from the Insurgency, I was able to slip
into Site-19 undetected, so that I could begin
my search.
The subterfuge was, at first, easy to maintain.
I looked the part, obviously.
A lab coat and name badge, so versatile and
yet completely unassuming.
I was visible and still imperceptible to the
rest of the Foundation’s personnel; as far
as they knew, I was just the latest transfer
to Site-19.
As I spent the day getting my bearings, not
one of them could have possibly known my true
intention.
My goal was simple and twofold.
First and foremost: I had long felt I deserved
to be accepted as a member of the art collective
known as ‘AWCY?’
or ‘Are We Cool Yet?’.
Since the nineteenth century, they have been
championing the creation and exhibition of
anomalous artwork, truly pushing the boundaries
of what can be considered artistic expression
despite the Foundation’s attempts to censor
AWCY’s transcendent art.
I had admired their mission statement from
afar, for a number of years, and strived to
achieve much the same in my own artwork.
However, none of my previous pieces quite
met the collective’s anomalous pedigree.
I know a way to change that, though…
Blending in at Site-19 proved to be fairly
simple; as long as you stride around with
purpose, few will question what you’re doing.
With my head in a notebook, or a look of conviction
on my face, I could freely make my way around
the facility.
But why, you might wonder?
What was the actual intention behind my undercover
mission?
Well, the answer lies in the second half of
my goal: recognition.
Not just notoriety and acceptance into the
ranks of AWCY, but fame throughout the anomalous
art world – and all the perks that could
come with.
Of course, the main hurdle to overcome was
I needed to create a piece of art that was
anomalous in its nature.
And so, rather than wait for inspiration and
materials to fall into my lap, I chose to
instead seek out what I needed.
The anomalies on offer at Site-19 were abundant,
and knowing where to start was tricky.
I made the decision, while still getting accustomed
to my new surroundings, that I would start
wherever I felt the most drawn to.
Before the end of my first week in Site-19,
I felt the first pull of an anomaly, and uncovered
it in the most unlikely of places.
During the day, most of the Foundation living
quarters are empty, meaning I could sneak
around there undetected.
It was in the personal bathroom of one Foundation
doctor that I found SCP-063.
To the untrained eye, the anomaly appears
to be an ordinary toothbrush, save for the
wording stenciled into its pale blue plastic:
“The World’s Best Tothbrush”.
Of course, examining it closer, I learned
of its ability to cleave through inorganic
matter like a hot knife through butter.
It was quite the shock, slicing the porcelain
of the bathroom’s sink by accident.
That would have led to my detection, had I
not left soon after.
But I reflected on the toothbrush – or ‘Tothbrush’
– and what it could possibly represent.
Perhaps an acknowledgment of rituals, and
their importance to human health.
Yet, at the same time, being sharp enough
to cut anything not organic – anything not
human – maybe SCP-063 was meant to symbolize
the possible dangers of habitual behaviors.
The next day, I was able to bear witness to
an anomalous piece I had only ever heard rumors
of.
For a time, I had thought it to have been
the reason for AWCY’s founding; after all
its nickname was derived from a particular
traditional art form.
SCP-173, The Sculpture, as those at the Foundation
call it.
I was able to insert myself into a group of
two other personnel; a researcher and security
officer.
The former was entering the container housing
SCP-173 to run tests, the latter protecting
her.
Naturally, I overheard them looking for a
third and offered my assistance, even if all
I had to do was watch The Sculpture intently.
I wasn’t even allowed to blink without getting
someone else to cover for me while I did.
I adored it.
The messy structure of concrete and rebar
defied all notions of what many believed art
should be; it wasn’t beautiful or pristine,
it dared to be ugly.
And yet, it demanded to be seen, to be looked
at and perceived, or else it would break my
neck and claim my life.
It was everything I’d hoped: pure art, personified.
It was as I neared the end of my first week
in Site-19 that I discovered my next anomalous
art piece, hidden away in a secure storage
locker.
SCP-010, the Collars of Control.
These were a collection of cast iron collars
that, according to their file, could be used
to control the actions and movements of a
person wearing one, via a remote control.
These collars fascinated me.
They were, to my interpretation, tools to
control yet simultaneously a rejection of
the very rules that control human beings.
Someone wearing an SCP-010 collar could potentially
have their entire bodily shape reconfigured
by the person wielding the remote.
That alone, the fact these objects could be
used to defy the physical laws that dictate
the forms we exist in, was a meta comment,
rejecting the laws of society in order for
free expression.
Expression only achieved by art; it all made
me appreciate AWCY’s dedication to anomalous
artworks.
Yet, I was still determined to be welcomed
into their collective.
My first week hiding within Site-19 concluded
with a visit to SCP-107.
Held on a pedestal in an otherwise empty room
was an empty, hollowed-out turtle shell.
Now, I, for one, don’t respect archaeologists.
Art historians are another matter; however,
I would rather focus on translating the human
experience into my art than waste mental energy
on events or objects from hundreds and thousands
of years ago.
But this turtle shell might be the exception.
Apparently, any liquid placed within the shell
will be absorbed, only to rain down from the
clouds above.
There’s something quite honest about SCP-107;
interpreted through the mind of an artist
such as myself, it appears to be a reminder
of the natural world’s cyclical process.
The liquid within it becomes rain, which falls
and feeds the plants.
The plant life in turn provides food and shelter
for animals, humans too, and so on.
On and on, the circle of life repeats, as
so embodied by the hollow shell of an ancient,
proud turtle.
I began my second week of subterfuge with
a scare, a close call that I may have been
discovered.
One of the Foundation doctor’s had complained
that his sink had been sliced in two, in spite
of my best efforts to cover my tracks.
It seemed that using his denture glue to repair
the damage SCP-063 had done didn’t quite
have the effect I had intended.
Nevertheless, the reaction by the Foundation
seemed to imply that that sort of thing happened
all the time.
An announcement was made reminding all researchers
not to toy with The World’s Best Tothbrush,
“despite how fun it was to slice things
up with”.
Although they requested the culprit come forward,
I decided to divert the Foundation’s suspicions
away from me, hinting to a security officer
I had seen Doctor Alto Clef leaving the private
bathroom where I had accidentally broken the
sink.
They seemed to believe he had been capable
of causing the damage.
Almost being discovered meant I had to reassess
my objective.
Over the following few days, I tried to sink
into life among the Foundation’s researchers,
playing the role of a helpful member of personnel
so as not to attract any further suspicions.
And so, I was mostly concerned with the general
day-to-day tending to anomalies.
Most of them I encountered during this time
were living creatures, which were of little
interest to me.
Although one, by the designation of SCP-049,
sported the rather aesthetically striking
appearance of a Plague Doctor, complete with
dark robes and a beaked mask.
At first, I thought him to be quite an amicable,
intelligent fellow.
That is, until I had a moment alone with him
to ask his opinions on art.
The Plague Doctor claimed it was ‘of little
importance’ when compared to curing ‘the
pestilence.
Naturally, I took that to be a personal insult,
requesting to the Research Head that I be
transferred away from an anomaly that was
obviously not as intelligent as I first thought.
Two and a half weeks had passed, and I had
still remained undetected by the Foundation.
However, I had been forced to reassess my
mission.
AWCY were hardly likely to accept me into
their group if I had nothing to show for my
efforts.
I needed either some materials I could use
to create an anomalous art piece or – preferably
– something I could claim as my own.
It wasn’t as if the upper echelons of AWCY
possessed their own detailed files on every
anomaly at Site-19.
They would have no idea if something I plucked
from containment was an existing SCP or a
Stathis Stern original piece.
So, I set about finding something that could
be my Magnum Opus, my breakthrough into the
anomalous art community – my key to the
fame, fortune, and artistic acclaim I so obviously
deserved.
You may call it plagiarism, using another
anomaly as my own piece, but nobody technically
owns the objects and entities at Site-19.
Even the Foundation themselves are more jailors,
and curators, than creators.
I, however, am a visionary – I just needed
something to prove it.
My search took me far and wide, all over the
width and breadth of Site-19.
By the time my first whole month had passed,
I had begun to walk its corridors and pass
by its containment chambers just like any
other researcher.
Although, not one who I interacted with had
any clue they were in the presence of the
man who would reshape the anomalous art world.
There was an SCP transferred from another
facility that I witnessed during that time.
According to the Foundation’s files, SCP-066
had previously been a ball of braided yarn
and ribbon, but had since become an amorphous
ball of meat with functioning eyes.
What struck me the most about SCP-066 was
the question it asked since transforming.
“Are you Eric?”
At first, I thought, I’m not Eric.
But the longer I pondered it, I began to wonder,
allowing my perception to be challenged.
That is what art does, after all.
Perhaps, much in the Marshal Mathers sense
that ‘We are all Stan’, all of us may
well be Eric too…
I can recall another incident encountering
some SCP-131s, creatures known as the Eye
Pods, when one almost tripped me up.
Their brightly-colored teardrop-shaped bodies
were certainly striking, a rather abstract,
modernist biomechanical design.
But it was their eyes that I found myself
ruminating on.
SCP-131 instances had a single, unblinking
eye, giving a constant gaze without faltering.
I likened it much to the uncritical, unthinking
eyes of certain audiences, who in the past
had started at my artwork and had nothing
interesting to say about it.
In other events, my attempts to avoid detection
may have proven a little detrimental.
Doctor Clef cornered me, a little perturbed
that I had implicated him in the ‘sink slicing’
incident.
He at one point he seemed to imply a desire
to inflict far worse damage with… a ukulele
of all things.
Although, I’m sure he was just joking.
At least, I hope so.
The whole interaction reminded me of the urgency
of my mission, I still needed my anomalous
masterpiece, and would need to have an escape
plan in place once I found it.
During my next stint of time hidden among
the ranks of the Foundation, I tried to broaden
my own interpretation of what AWCY would consider
to be ‘art’.
Nothing in their admittedly vaguely defined
rules stated my anomalous piece couldn’t
be created from a more modern medium.
Never mind paintings that can depict a person’s
death or a sculpture that moves whenever unobserved,
what about something like photography, I thought
to myself.
However, it was around this time that my hopes
for such a piece were seemingly answered,
in the form of SCP-105, or Iris Thompson as
she introduced herself.
Iris had a rather unique relationship with
the art of photography.
She possessed an ability to alter images taken
on a specific Polaroid Express camera from
1982.
In the hands of SCP-105, the photographs would
come to life, like slices of real-time frozen
one moment then moving the second she held
them.
She could even alter these images, reaching
into the Polaroid to move or retrieve objects.
It instilled an idea in me, perhaps taking
a polaroid of my chosen anomalous art, would
be enough.
That is, until I realized the photographs
were only interactable to Iris, and breaking
her out of containment was a waste of my skills
as an artist.
Partway into my third month hiding out in
Site-19, part of me began to wonder if the
Foundation’s security forces were as formidable
as I’d been led to believe.
It seemed I barely even needed to hide my
mission to join AWCY, or that I had spent
so much time in their facility undetected.
It was on my sixty-eighth day that I decided
to reflect on some of the potential anomalous
pieces I had encountered so far.
Frustratingly so, I was still yet to discover
any that would wipe the smug grins off the
AWCY members, only to replace them with looks
of awe.
Something in Site-19 would guarantee my spot
among the anomalous art collective, I was
certain of it.
I just had to find it.
A potential candidate presented itself, one
that might have even allowed me to get my
own back on AWCY for denying my entry for
so long.
I was shown SCP-3037, a miniature model that
depicted the city of Dubrovnik in Croatia.
I was watching it and pondering the meaning
behind this sculpture, thinking about why
it had been made specifically to look like
Dubrovnik, of all places.
Maybe, I pondered, it was meant to be a commentary
or condemnation of urbanization, given the
city’s walls keeping its residents contained,
confined, much like how we as humans have
become trapped by our urban settings, finding
comfort in being confined there.
However, it was while examining SCP-3037 that
I apparently suffered something of an incident.
From the moment I touched it, I spoke in only
Serbo-Croatian, believing myself to actually
be the city of Dubrovnik.
I awoke a short while later, and was informed
by another researcher that I had been administered
with an extremely high dose of amnestics to
negate the effects of SCP-3037.
Although later that night, I recalled having
a dream about some delicious Black Risotto
with squid ink sauce.
The Research heads ordered security officers
to gather everyone in the mess hall.
The Foundation was seemingly aware that they
had an imposter, a charlatan, in their midst
pretending to be a member of personnel.
I made sure my facial expression did not betray
that I was the one they sought.
Not one of these philistines could appreciate
my goal of infiltrating Site-19.
Not one had the slightest clue how revolutionary
my actions would be for the art world.
However, although staying vigilant, I became
increasingly aware time might not be on my
side much longer.
After overhearing a conversation about something
known as SCP-035, I began conducting my own
secretive research into what it was.
I discovered information on the so-called
‘Possessive Mask’ within the Foundation’s
archives.
Immediately, my heart skipped a beat, the
porcelain mask that shifted from an exaggerated
comedic grin to a wide frown; it would have
made for a perfect art piece to present to
AWCY.
Much to my annoyance, SCP-035 wasn’t housed
at Site-19, however.
Over the next few days, I petitioned to have
the Possessive Mask transferred to the facility
so I could claim it.
My greatest anomalous art piece stayed out
of reach though.
I was informed by senior research staff that
the mask posed a potential danger; anyone
nearby was compelled to wear it and would
thus be taken over by its influence.
Additionally, questions started to be raised
as to why I was requesting this transfer in
the first place.
I was starting to grow concerned that my cover
had been blown.
By now, it very much seemed that my time was
running out.
And although it shames me to admit, to say
I handled that notion with grace and professionality…
well, that would be a lie.
Suddenly, I found it: the perfect anomalous
art piece.
While rummaging around the Foundation’s
files, I located one about something known
as SCP-1379.
As I read more, I realized it would secure
my spot within AWCY and forever grant me the
recognition I deserved.
Even better: it was a painting!
Such a classical art medium, they’d never
be able to refuse me!
As I looked at it directly for the first time,
I knew I had found my masterpiece.
SCP-1379 depicted a clown and two children
on the canvas.
But the subject of the painting would hardly
matter to AWCY, they only cared that the artwork
was anomalous.
And SCP-1379 certainly was.
This painting would allow me to exact revenge
on the AWCY members who’d failed to recognize
my artistic genius for so long.
Anyone that made a critical remark on SCP-1379
– which those AWCY snobs were bound to do
when they saw it – would first experience
intense pain.
After twenty minutes of sharp, severe agony,
the sensations would subside.
But that’d only be the start of it.
Everyone at the AWCY that dared to criticize
my Magnum Opus, my SCP-1379, would rapidly
lose their ability to imagine.
Any of their creativity that had allowed them
to laud their artistic superiority over me
would cease to exist.
None of them would ever make anomalous art
again, and they’d surely be forced to finally
accept that I am, in fact, the greatest artist
of all time.
From the moment I saw it, I began to plan
my escape, with SCP-1379 in tow.
A hundred days have passed since I arrived
here, and when I leave, it will be with SCP-1379
and this journal.
I’ve not only chronicled how I infiltrated
the SCP Foundation, but also cataloged more
about anomalous art than anyone at AWCY ever
has.
Once I’ve lifted that painting from its
containment locker, my old friends at the
Insurgency have arranged for me to be extracted
from Site-19.
With SCP-1379, finally I’ll achieve my dream
of-
This journal – belonging to one Stathis
Sterns – has been seized by the SCP Foundation.
Sterns was discovered to have infiltrated
Site-19 after only a handful of days.
However, given that he posed little threat,
and never left the facility, security officers
were instructed to monitor him closely until
he attempted to escape.
Aware of intelligence regarding various SCPs
noted within his journal, the Foundation deemed
Stathis Sterns a security risk after one-hundred
days.
Subject was arrested attempting to escape
and is to be administered amnestics.
His journal will remain at Site-19 until further
notice.
Now go and check out “I Survived 100 Days
of SCP-001 When Day Breaks...
Here's What Happened” and “I Survived
100 Days in SCP-3008...
Here's What Happened” for more thrilling
100 day survival challenges!